the One Piece manga just confirmed one
of the most popular theories which is
that Blackbeard absolutely can eat a
third devil fruit and this mind-blowing
reveal comes with massive implications
for the story as Blackbeard considers
whether or not to eat the opiopinomi
after defeating Trafalgar law and even
though law manages to somehow Escape we
now know that Blackbeard will surely be
hunting for a third supremely powerful
devil fruit to pair with the strongest
devil fruits in the story and yet that's
not the only epic Clash in this chapter
as we get confirmation that the former
Fleet Admiral aokiji is actually one of
Blackbeard's Titanic captains and that
he is on Pirate Island right now to stop
GARP from rescuing Kobe but that is not
going to be an easy feat as we get even
more ridiculous evidence that GARP is
just the most insanely powerful Marine
in the story and somehow if all of that
wasn't enough yet we also learned even
more clues about aokiji's mysterious his
time after leaving the Marines and more
hints about where the elusive fourth
Road poniglyph might be as well starting
off with the Epic conclusion to law vs
Blackbeard now in chapter 1063 we first
see law and Blackbeard Clash on winter
Island and in this all-out battle law
used his god-like devil fruit to fend
off the darkness and the earthquake
fruit at the same time but the fighting
has finally reached its conclusion as we
see a bloodied and panting Blackbeard
standing over a defeated law and it's in
this scene that we seem to finally get
as close to an answer as we've ever had
to one of the biggest mysteries in all
of One Piece that's because ever since
Marine Ford when Blackbeard did the
unthinkable and took whitebeard's devil
fruit for himself we have always
wondered if he would be able to eat a
third devil fruit as well and the answer
seems to be yeah as Blackbeard openly
wonders if we should take lost powers
for himself and use them or just sell
the coveted opioid me for that the
highest bidder and while he doesn't
outright say that he wants to eat it
here we can basically assume that he is
talking about himself for a few reasons
first off the Japanese really makes it
sound like it's meant for him and also
all of his other Titanic captains
already have devil fruit so unless
anyone can eat two devil fruits not just
blackbeards that rules out all of them
and I really don't think that Blackbeard
would give it to just some Rando of his
crew so that really only leaves himself
as an option to eat the opioid me for
himself however if Blackbeard actually
decided to sell it there is one group in
particular who would definitely be
interested in this fruit and that is the
world governments now we've known that
they've been after this specific fruit
since we saw them try so hard to obtain
it during Law's heartbreaking flashback
and then during the last chapter we
learned that Blackbeard wants to
officially join the world government as
a kingdom so maybe instead of capturing
Kobe it would have been smarter to try
and trade the Ope opinomi in exchange
for membership in the world government
but whether he wanted to eat it or a
trade lost fruit in for money or power
or whatever this mind-blowing reveal
really brings out the old question of
how exactly can Blackbeard eat more than
one devil fruit in the first place now
we don't get any clues that anyone else
in this crew is able to do this so it
truly seems like this ability is
specific to Blackbeard himself but is
that now personally I am dying to know
but a few theories that we've discussed
before on this channel are that
Blackbeard has multiple personalities or
people that there's something weird
about his body that allows him to eat
multiple devil fruits or it could be
some other super secret power of the
darkness Rouge that we just don't know
about yet kind of like how Luffy's fruit
turned out to be something completely
different it is also unclear if
Blackbeard would need to kill law in
order to take his devil fruit as law is
clearly still alive in this chapter and
every time we've seen devil fruits taken
or talked about being taken it somehow
involved someone needing to be killed
for example with whitebeard's death and
Marine Ford and when Burgess wanted to
take Luffy's fruit Andres Rosa but while
Blackbeard takes his time to decide what
to do this scene takes a wild turn of
events last loyal Ming polar bear Beppo
takes a rumble ball which he clearly got
from Chopper during wano which allows
him to enter the Ming sulong form and
normally this form can only be used
during the full moon but apparently this
drug or Rumble ball that was developed
by Chopper allows them to enter the form
whenever they want which is so
interesting because we're getting even
more evidence that Chopper is truly
becoming a medical genius but also why
didn't they use that Jerry wano anyways
in this beastly truly amazing looking
form Beppo is able to steal law away
from all the Blackbeard Pirates and
Escape into the sea leaving the other
members of lost crew abandoned on the
island which leaves us all with a super
interesting question where does log go
from here and does he still have his
fruit there are multiple options here
first Egghead Island should be somewhat
close by since law and Luffy both came
to these islands directly after parting
paths eduano so yeah it is possible that
Beppo will take lot to Egghead where
they will encounter the straw hats once
again and even though law and Luffy
declared their Lions over I could see
law asking for Luffy's help if it meant
saving his men who knows maybe this and
kids defeat might mean that both of them
actually join the crew however another
completely different option and one that
personally has me extremely excited is
that Beppo could take law to his home
Island zone now this would of course
bring the enormous walking elephants
Anisha back into the story as we've only
seen it for a brief few chapters when it
came to wanna clearly zunisha still has
some important role to play in the story
so this could be one way to reintroduce
the massive elephant once again and even
more exciting is the entire country of
Ming's living on zanesha's back because
whether this was a rumble ball or some
sort of new medicine it can let Mings go
so long whenever they choose and this
entire country who are now allies with
Luffy just would get way stronger than
it already was we already saw in wano
that sulong Mings can be devastating
Fighters so a whole country a whole Army
of these ferocious animals would be
insanely powerful for the battle still
to come and of course there is no
greater upcoming battle than the race to
find the one piece and with law defeated
we can assume that Blackbeard has now
taken his copies of the roadponent
glyphs just like Shanks did with kit
which are necessary to reach the final
Island Loft tale and we did a full
breakdown of who has which road ponig
live in a recent chapter review but
basically this means that Blackbeard now
has at least two of the road Pony glyphs
and as we will discuss in just a few
minutes he is likely to get at least one
more very soon but now that law is
defeated this means that the final
players in the race to find the one
piece are now all set law and Captain
Kidd who were just defeated by Shanks
are no longer serious contenders which
basically just leaves us with Luffy
Shanks Blackbeard and of course the most
important character buggy slash cross
kills come on you can never leave Buggy
Out of these kind of important events
anyways and he is a yongo he'll
definitely be there but now we have to
ask what will Blackbeard do
on will he pursue another strong devil
fruit to take as his own or just move on
to wherever his next objective is and if
he's going hunting for a third devil
fruit we have to ask of course what
power does Blackbeard actually want for
himself and while in this chapter it
does seem like we got a hint that he
isn't quite dead set yet on a particular
devil fruit to eat as his third power
and it seems as if he wasn't sure if you
wanted to eat the OPI fruit for himself
or not so maybe he is still undecided or
simply waiting to see what supremely
overpowered devil fruit he can get his
hands on so it is certainly possible
that he will try to chase after law and
people to take back the ope opinomi but
if he can't do that there are some other
fantastic options for fruit that he
could really want and personally I've
never really thought it makes a lot of
sense for him to eat another logia fruit
as I don't know how he could be darkness
and another element at the same time so
it basically leaves us with a Zone power
or a paramecia fruit and of course there
are a few really strong Zone fruits that
black beard crit Target titles defeat
Blackbeard could be after his mythical
devil fruit or with kaido not ruling
over wano he could also try to sneak in
and go after two other mythical fruits
still on the island those are Momo's
version of the dragon fruit and Yamato's
okochino makami fruit which lets her
turn into this wolf Guardian deity and
Blackbeard sneaking into wano would make
sense because we just saw the black bear
pirate sneak into big mom's territory to
kidnap big mom's daughter pudding but
besides wano there's currently a large
Gathering of strong devil fruit users on
Egghead Island so Blackbeard could
simply join the Epic conflict there in
order to steal some sort of devil fruit
such as the leopard fruit or even
stussy's unnamed vampire like fruit or
there's also Luffy it is also entirely
possible that vegapunk has a storehouse
of strong devil fruits on akken island
that could be taken during the fighting
as well and of course there are also the
straw hat double fruits that Blackbeard
could have his eye on and actually
speaking of the straw hats has anyone
else noticed that it has now been three
whole chapters since we've actually seen
any of our main characters I mean how
crazy is it that in the middle of an arc
like that we just get completely
different characters but it's somehow
even more epic than that but personally
I'm not complaining since we just keep
getting these juicy incredible chapters
outside the events of Egghead Island and
remember we have seen one of the
Blackbeard ships arriving at eckhit
island but if Blackbeard doesn't Chase
Law or go to any of these islands I just
mentioned then the most likely option is
simply that he will return to his home
base which is Pirate Island to join the
Earth shattering conflict between the
increasingly badass GARP and his former
pupil kuzan and this class will
undoubtedly have a massive effect on the
future of the Blackbeard Pirates which
we will discuss in full detail in just a
moment but on a quick side note since
kuzan is no longer an admiral we won't
use his Admiral nickname aokiji anymore
since he is not Aoki anymore and instead
just call him by his actual name which
is kuza but before we
get that Titanic big fight we see a
flashback about the first time that
kuzan actually met with Blackbeard now
we're being told that this event is
roughly a year after kuzan lost his
devastating Island warping battle
against the current Fleet Admiral akinu
after this battle kuzan left the Marines
because he couldn't stand taking orders
from Akainu and we aren't told what
kuzan has been doing in between that
fight and this scene here in the
flashback but there are a number of
hints that we can try to use and
figuring that out for example in chapter
698 we see kuzan for the very first time
after the time skip when he saved vice
admiral smoker on Punk hazards and in
that conversation kuzan's outfit kind of
seems to suggest that he's still
wandering as a loner and has not yet
joined the Blackbeard Pirates I mean
just look at the difference between this
outfit and these that he's wearing right
now is one of Blackbeard's 10 Titanic
captains like clearly something changed
in the few months since Punk Hazard
however at the same time if it's one
year after timeline wise kind of doesn't
add up really now Blackbeard could have
offered kuzan to join him halfway
through the two-year time skip right
here as we see in the flashback but he
might have taken a while before actually
accepting the offer to join the empress
crew it's kind of weird timeline wise
but regardless it's clear that kuzan has
been acting on his own for some time
during and after the time skip which
does make me wonder what exactly he was
doing then now Blackbeard even said in
this chapter that pirates can still have
their own agenda so maybe Blackbeard
just lets kuzan do whatever he wants
unless directly ordered by Blackbeard as
he is clearly right now but the clearest
answer to all of the speculation and the
one most people expect is that he has
resigned from the Marines and joined the
secret Marine organization sword himself
we just learned in chapter 1080 that all
the members of Sword are former Marines
who are no longer affiliated with the
world government so that they can
basically act on their own behalf
without waiting for the okay from higher
ups basically they are like GARP who
pretty much does whatever he wants
anyways and the evidence for kuzan being
a member of Sword is made even clearer
when we compare some of kuzan's dialogue
from chapter 699 to what we just learned
in this chapter take a look at what
kuzan says while talking to smoka first
he states that you don't have to be
affiliated with the Navy to accomplish
things and that there are some things
that you can only see when you remain
independent I mean that is also exactly
how sword was described in chapter 1080
so it makes complete sense to me at
least that he's still acting on his own
belief as a member of Swords but
nonetheless I mean you know what happens
in this chapter and at the end of his
conversation with smoker he even warns
the vice admiral about the dangers of no
flamingo in dressrosa and then went on
to tell the Marines to not reveal that
they had seen him and it makes sense
that he would only care about these
things if one was part of a secret
Marine organization and two he planned
to go undercover and didn't want black
finding out that he was still
helping his own buddies so personally it
does still seem to all line up that he
has infiltrated Blackbeard's crew with
some intention of betraying Blackbeard
later on in the story and it wouldn't be
Oda of course if he didn't set up a red
herring trying to distract us a little
bit from that fact but back to the
flashback that we see in this chapter
now Blackbird arrives on the scene and
three of his Titanic captains are
already frozen solid by kuzan's ice
powers and while one of Blackbeard's
allies thinks that it would be best to
kill kuzan right away they instead have
a jolly all-time drinking and having fun
inside the bar also it does seem like
Huzan could kill all of them if he
wanted to here which pretty badass from
his end and who knows maybe kuzan has
actually changed since joining the
Marines but this is certainly not the
laid-back lazy and emotionless dude that
we are used to seeing which still makes
me think even more that this is all an
act that he's putting on just two full
blackbeards and eventually Blackbeard
asks who's on about the man with the
burn scar because he thinks that this
person might have the final Road
poniglyph like kid also suggested at the
end of wano and this was truly a massive
shock when I read this I mean we barely
learned about this mysterious figure in
chapter 1056. kids knew about him and
his connections to the one piece but if
Blackbeard's crew knew about him over a
year ago just how secretive is this guy
well we did get some more information
about who this could possibly be back in
chapter 1066. there we learned that the
giant former Marine Saul who we thought
was killed during the destruction of
Ohara was most likely alive so it makes
a lot of sense that he is the man marked
by Flames since he literally was running
through flames on O'Hara and he could
have ice burns after being frozen by
kuzan and we see him wrapped in bandages
in this panel right here now since Saul
was connected to the incident of Ohara
and those same Scholars were studying
the polyglips it would be logical that
Saul could be protecting the final Road
Pony live us we already know from Vega
punch flashback that the Giants of elbaf
Savaged everything that they could find
from Ohara so it would certainly be
reasonable for the final Road Pony glyph
to be on albaf with Saul and while kuzan
does actively denies knowing anything
about the man marked by Flames or the
final Road ponig live and saying that he
didn't see anything like a road Pony
glyph on O'Hara he could just be lying
to protect Saul and the pony glyphs
since they were friends and yet another
rumor that is hinted at in this scene is
that the man marked by Flames traveled
on a black ship and has some sort of
ability to create massive whirlpools and
a black ship makes me think of this ship
which was captained by roxyzebec now
another option is that it could be
referring to the leader of the
Revolutionary Army of course Monkey D
Dragon after all whirlpools can be
formed by strong winds and we do know
dragon has some kind of wind weather
power since he basically always is
accompanied by strong wins whenever he
appears in the story plus we found out
recently that Dragon also has ties to
the scholars of Ohara so it is possible
that dragon and Saul became allies after
the events on Ohara also he does have
that face tattoo which might have to do
something with flames who knows could
interpret it that way but all of this
makes me wonder how anyone knows about
the man marked by flames in the first
place I mean if this person is Saul then
he should have been in hiding for
literally decades but somehow Blackbeard
and even kid had heard rumors about him
so could there be any traitors within
the Giants of elbeth or is this
mysterious figure simply someone
completely different and new that we
haven't even met yet whatever the answer
is it'll clearly be just as exciting as
The mouth-watering Clash that we get
between kuzan and GARP on Pirate Island
in this chapter I mean we first see
kuzan freeze Kobe's friends and then
after a brief bit of dialogue kuzan
freezes GARP with an ice ball attack
just like he did against Whitebeard
during Marine Forts and of course just
like his legendary former rival GARP
easily breaks out of the ice and in a
burst of blinding speed GARP grabs kuzan
face in a hockey covered Fist and slams
him into the ground with such tremendous
power that it reminds me of all the
ground shattering attacks that Luffy has
used to defeat his opponents over the
years truly one family but of course
beside this mind-blowing action there's
also a ton to unpack from the brief
dialogue between these two as well now
before they Clash kuzan reveals that he
was actually trained by gar personally
sometime in the past this leads even
more evidence to the theory that kuzan
is secretly a member of Sword since Kobe
and helmeppel are both members of Sword
as well and they were both trained by
Garth and I mean I don't know maybe this
is just crazy levels of copium I'm
having right here on my part because he
certainly doesn't look very friendly
during this Clash seriously if he is
secretly undercover then he is putting
on a painful amount of effort into
convincing the black Bay Pirates and
everyone around there that he is still
on their side I mean if he is an
undercover agent touche for those acting
skills out kiji and while it appears
that GARP has the advantage in this epic
battle we simply never know with fights
in one piece how it'll actually turn out
I mean this could change very quickly
maybe kuzan isn't taking this fight
seriously yet or maybe the other
Blackbeard Titanic captains will come in
and to gather overwhelm GARP or maybe
GARP will once again prove that he is
simply the strongest marine and just
wipe them all out anyways and it's still
not all that we can learn from this
legendary battle because since kuzan is
now confirmed to be here on Pirate
Island this information partially solves
a mystery from chapter 2079 because for
a single panel in that chapter we saw
that one of Blackbeard ships is
currently just outside of Egghead
Islands now previously I thought that
this might be kuzan himself since it
would make sense for him to join a
conflict with the world government but
clearly that's not the case and since
kuzan is here on this island right now
we now have a pretty good idea of who is
coming to Egghead Island right now there
are these five to ten captains here on
Pirate Island and currently accompanying
Blackbeard are those three which only
leaves Lafitte and Katarina Devon or
Blackbeard himself and the rest of his
crew but honestly it does make perfect
sense for these two to be the ones
coming to eckat Island because there is
no one better at sneaking around on
Blackbeard's crew than these two are
right here we already know that lafeat
is super stealthy as he even managed to
sneak into marijua he has some sort of
hypnosis powers and he can even fly with
his wings but even better for trickery
is Katarina Devon who has the
shape-shifting powers of the mythical
nine-tailed fox devil fruit and so
together these two form the perfect pair
to steal into the chaos of eckat Island
and take whatever they want it could be
the copies of the roponic list that the
straw ads have or it could be that they
have their eyes on a super strong devil
fruit that they want to capture for
someone else if they die and so really
whenever one conflict seems to be
wrapping up here the others are just
getting more incredible with every
chapter and I just cannot wait to see
who comes out on top in each of these
world-changing battles and if you want
to know why The Godly powers of guard
will completely change the rest of the
story you can watch that analysis right
here thanks for watching and I see you
in the next one